ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHEN CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LEAD
LEVINE. LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE TAKING BALLOT THERE. VIA
FOOD ROCK VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WHAT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WHERE OUR GUESTS AND
IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER. AND IN
THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. DAYS PRAYER. WE'LL
BE ALL BY OUR A CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YES SIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD
. REVEALED THE BLESSINGS OF
DIVERSITY AND THE MANY SHAPES
AND FORMS BUT IT HAS BECOME
MANIFEST IN OUR COMMUNITY AND IN
OUR WORLD. MAY WE SEE OUR
DIFFERENCES AS A SOURCE OF
STRENGTH. MAY IT ALWAYS BE USED
TO UNITE. AND NOT TO DESTROY MAY
JUST BE GUARDS WILL I MEAN. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
LUCKY. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS
PRIVILEGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. STATES OF AMERICA-
ASIAN. INDIVISIBLE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY DECEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PURSUANT TO THE
PROVISIONS OF JOINT RULE FIFTY
NINE THE FOLLOWING US IN THE
JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
REGULAR SESSIONS PRINT WHILE THE
ASSEMBLY WAS AN INTERNAL. ERROR
COOLEY MOOSE. M. IS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. PARTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL B DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. WE ARE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MEMBERS
WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
AND MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
GOOD MORNING OF UNDER MATTER OF
HOUSEKEEPING ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY EVER QUESTION ANIMUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
SOME REMEMBERS CORK SILVA BLOOM
MURATSUCHI AND RAMOS TO SPEAK ON
A GERMAN AND MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUED TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO REFER TO
THE FOLLOWING BILL COMMITTEE. AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE RODRIGUEZ FOR
THE EDUCATION TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY EIGHT A SUMMER MCCARTY
IS GIVEN A ONE DAY NOTICE REMOVE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE AN
ACTIVE FILE ITEM AS THIRTEEN AB
FORTY NINETY ONE ITEM A FOURTEEN
AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN. ITEM A
SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
AND ITEM EIGHT TWENTY FIVE AB
NINE TWENTY ONE. FURTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES IS GIVEN A
ONE DAY NOTICE FOR BROUGH ITEM A
FIFTY SIX SB FIVE OH FIVE FOUR
BY SENATOR BAKER FROM INACTIVE
FILE. THE CLERK WILL NOTE. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES TO NOTICE BILLS
PENDING REFERRAL TO ALLOW THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTED NOTICE AB
TWELVE OR SIX. BY SUMMER BENNETT
FOR THE HEARING ON JANUARY
TWELFTH PITTED REFERRAL FOR THE
REGULAR TAXATION COMMITTEE. AND
ALLOW JUDICIARY COMMITTEE DOES
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THEIR
JANUARY THIRTEENTH TERRY. AB SIX
SEVEN SIX BY A SUMMER HOLDEN
PITTED RIFFLE REFERRAL FROM THE
BUSINESS NUMBER VERSUS
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT SEVENTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO PENNY
REFERRAL FROM VINYL SAFE IN
TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE AND AB
TWELVE FORTY ONE BY SUMMER JONES
SAWYER AND AB FOURTEEN TEN BY
SUMMER RODRIGUEZ. A REFERRAL
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. FINALLY I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY SIX
WITHDRAW AB TWELVE TWELVE BY
SUMMER WOULD THE GOVERNOR'S RACE
COMMITTEE AND ORDER THE BILL TO
THE SECOND READ FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISS COOLEY. YEAH.
MEMBERS
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
GOVERNOR'S VETOES FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FORTY FIVE THE ITEMS
SHALL BE CONTINUED. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEM FORTY
SIX. XABI CONTINUED MORE. ON
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEMS FORTY SEVEN AND FORTY
EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED. AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES. WHO WILL BE A
TURNING IN THE MEMORY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CLARK
SILVA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. TODAY I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MR
JAMES DO ONE ON WHO PASSED AWAY
ON DECEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND DR JOY CHUNG JOB ON WHO
PASSED AWAY ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTH. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
THE COUPLE WERE LONGTIME
RESIDENTS OF LA PALMA AND
PILLARS OF THE COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY MARRIED FOR FIFTY SIX
YEARS THE COUPLE PASSED AWAY
WITHIN DAYS OF EACH OTHER. THEIR
LIFE TOGETHER CONSISTED OF THREE
MAJOR THEMES STRUGGLE AND
PERSEVERANCE HOPE IN LOVE AND
COMMITMENT TO ONE ANOTHER AND
THEIR FAMILY. WELL LIVING IN
KOREA DR JOY ON. EXCELLED
ACADEMICALLY AND GRADUATED FROM
EQUALITY WOMEN'S UNIVERSITY
UNIVERSITY COREA'S VERSION OF
RADCLIFFE WOMEN'S COLLEGE WHICH
IS NOW PART OF HARVARD. AS A
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL DR JOY ON
FIRMLY BELIEVED IN THE
HIPPOCRATIC OATH SHE WOULD TREAT
PEOPLE FROM ALL WHITE WALKS OF
LIFE IN OUR PHARMACY CLINIC
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY FOR MEDICINE. SHE WAS ALSO
AN ENTREPREEUR AND OPENED ONE
OF THE FIRST PHARMACY AND HEALTH
CLINICS IN HER NEIGHBORHOOD. AS
A MOTHER AND COMMUNITY LEADER
SHE WAS ASSERTIVE AND DEMANDED
EQUAL TREATMENT AND SOCIETY FOR
HER AND HER FAMILY. WELL IN HIGH
SCHOOL MISTER JAMES ON PRACTICE
CALLIGRAPHY AND HIS PAINTINGS
WERE DISPLAYED IN THE BLUE HOUSE
THE KOREAN. EQUIVALENT OF OUR
WHITE HOUSE FOLLOWING HIGH
SCHOOL MISTER JAMES ON WAS
DRAFTED BY THE REPUBLIC OF
KOREA'S ARMY AND LATER JOINED
THE INTELLIGENCE SERVICE HE
WORKED WITH THE U. S. CENTRAL
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY TO CONDUCT
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE AND-
MISSIONS AGAINST THREATS ON THE
KOREAN PENINSULA AND HELPED
ESTABLISH THE COUNTY'S FIRST
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
LOVE WHAT INTO THEIR LIVES
THROUGH A CHANCE OF MEETINGS AS
A PATIENT AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL SMITTEN BY THE
PHARMACISTS WHO TREATED. HIS ARE
ALLERGIC REACTION JAMES PURSUED
A RELUCTANT ENJOY AND TELL HE
FELL FINALLY WON HER HEART THE
COME UP COUPLE IMMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES FROM KOREA IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX ULTIMATELY
SETTLING AND LA PALMA. MISTER
AND MRS D ON WERE OUTSTANDING
LEADERS IN THE KOREAN COMMUNITY
SERVING ON MANY MANY KOREAN
BOARDS INCLUDING THE KOREAN
FEDERATION KOREAN SENIOR
CITIZENS ASSOCIATION KOREAN
VETERANS ASSOCIATION. THE ONS
ALSO FOUNDED THE CREAN MID CITY
ASSOCIATION AND THE KOREAN
AMERICAN WEDDING BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION I ASK THAT YOU KEEP
THE ON FAMILY IN YOUR THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS. THANK YOU MISS CORE
SILVA MISTER MURATSUCHI ON THE
CENTERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO WANT
TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FULLERTON- TO ASK. THE ASSEMBLY
TO TURN IN THE MEMORY OF DR JOY
IN JAMES ON. WHO IS. THE PARENTS
OF MY GOOD FRIEND AND A GOOD
FRIEND FOR MANY OF US ON THIS
FLOOR. OF JAIL ON AS WELL AS HIS
BROTHER JONATHAN. THE STORY OF
THE JEWS ON FAMILY IS A CLASSIC
CURRENT AMERICAN IMMIGRANT STORY
. JAMES SERVED WITH DISTINCTION
IN THE SOUTH KOREAN MILITARY.
WHILE HIS WIFE DR CHOI ON
GRADUATED FROM THE PRESTIGIOUS
YOU ARE WOMEN'S UNIVERSITY IN
SEOUL KOREA. BUT THEY LEFT IT
ALL IN KOREA TO START A NEW LIFE
IN AMERICA TO PURSUE BETTER
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE SO MANY
IMMIGRANTS IN OUR COUNTRY. THEY
STRUGGLED AS OWNERS AND
OPERATORS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
WHILE VOLUNTEERING COUNTLESS
HOURS AT THEIR CURRENT AMERICAN
CHURCH. AGAIN IN A STORY THAT WE
HEAR OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN THE
CURRENT AMERICAN COMMUNITY. THEY
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY WITHIN A
WEEK OF EACH OTHER. AS IF. JAMES
WAS CHASING AFTER HIS WIFE JOY
HIS WIFE OF OVER FIFTY SIX YEARS
. THEY LEAVE A PROUD LEGACY WITH
THEIR SONS MY GOOD FRIEND JOE ON
HIS BROTHER. AND HIS THE REST OF
THEIR FAMILIES AND I AND AGAIN I
ASK THAT WE JOIN A MEMORY OF DR
JOINED JAMES ON. THANK YOU
MISTER MURATSUCHI. MISTER BLOOM
WE ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF MS
JACQUELYN A FONT. IS A FONT
WHOSE LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY CUT
SHORT LAST DECEMBER IN A VIOLENT
HOME INVASION. WAS AN EIGHTY
FIFTY CONSTITUENT AND WIFE OF
LEGENDARY MUSIC AND FILM
PRODUCER CLARENCE AVON'S. MS
JACQUELYN ABBOTT WAS BORN
JACQUELINE ALBERTA GRAY ON MARCH
SIXTH NINETEEN FORTY IN QUEENS
NEW YORK. AS A YOUNG WOMAN SHE
BECAME A MODEL INCLUDING FOR
EBONY FASHION FAIR WHICH WAS
NOTED FOR INTRODUCING NEW UP AND
COMING STYLE TO THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. DECLAN AVON MATTER
FUTURE HUSBAND CLARENCE IN THE
MID SIXTIES THEY MARRIED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN AND HEAD
WEST TO LOS ANGELES WHERE SUSSEX
RECORDS WAS BORN. CLARENCE HEARD
BILL WITHERS DEMOS SIGNED HIM
AND THEY ALONG WITH BOOKER T.
JONES CRAFTED THE TIMELESS IT
AIN'T NO SUNSHINE. THE REST IS
HISTORY BY THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AND INTO THE EIGHTIES
. JACQUELYN HUSBAND CLARENCE
WERE MAJOR POWER PLAYERS NOT
ONLY IN LOS ANGELES'S MUSIC
SCENE BUT ALSO THE POLITICAL
SPHERE. THEY FAMOUSLY HELPED
ELECT LA'S FIRST AND ONLY BLACK
MAYOR TOM BRADLEY WHILE
SUPPORTING OTHER BUDDING YOUNG
BLACK POITICIANS LIKE FORMER
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN.
AND MANY WHO SERVE ON THIS VERY
FLOOR. WHEN JACQUELINE AVON
WASN'T BUSY WITH MUSIC AND
POLITICS HE GENEROUSLY LENT HER
TIME TO A HOST OF IMPORTANT
CAUSES INCLUDING THE UCLA
INTERNATIONAL STUDENT CENTER THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
WOMEN'S ENTERTAINMENT DIVISION
AND THE NEIGHBORS OF WHAT'S-
ADDITIONALLY SHE VOLUNTEERED AS
A DOCENT FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY MUSEUM OF ART. WHERE SHE
TOOK AN INTEREST IN JAPANESE ART
BEGAN HER OWN COLLECTION. THE
AVON SEVEN DESCRIBED AS THE GLUE
BETWEEN MUSIC ENTERTAINMENT AND
POLITICS IN LOS ANGELES AND THAT
JACQUELINE KNOWN AS JACKIE TO
OUR FRIENDS WAS THE QUEEN OF THE
PEOPLE. JACQUELYN AVON IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND CLARENCE
OF OVER FIFTY YEARS AND THEIR
TWO CHILDREN NICOLE AND
ALEXANDER AND I REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN AND JACQUELINE AVON'S
MEORY. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
M. MISTER RAMOS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. IT IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT OUR RIGHTS TO
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF GAVE DELAROSA WHO
PASSED ON NEW YEAR'S EVE. OUR
DEEPEST CONSULT CONDOLENCES TO
GO OUT TO HIS WIFE ANGIE AND HIS
CHILDREN AND EXTENDED FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. GAME WAS A LONGTIME
FRIEND AND UNFAILING ADVOCATE
FOR THE COMMUNITY OF MENTAL. AND
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES OF
SEMINAL COUNTING. HE NEVER
FAILED TO GIVE OF HIS TIME HIS
RESOURCES EXPERIENCE OR CHAIR. I
MET MR DELAROSA AT THE HOME AND
NEIGHBORLY SERVICE IN SAMBAR
DINO IN AN AREA CALLED MOUNT
VERNON. GAVE HIS MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS INCLUDE SERVING AS
PRESIDENT CHAIRMAN OF THE
MENTONE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE FOR
ABOUT TWO YEARS AND FORMALLY AS
VICE PRESIDENT. HE WAS ALSO
PRESIDENT OF THE MENTONE AREA
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION FOR NINE
YEARS. AND LAST YEAR. HE WAS
HONORED FOR ALL OF HIS WORK. AND
FOR THE FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AS NONPROFIT OF THE
YEAR. GAVE ATTENDED MANY SALMON
YOU KNOW COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MEETINGS LASKO IN
CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS. HE ALSO
OPERATED THE. MINISTRIES FOR
SEVERAL YEARS TO AID THE LESS
FORTUNATE. HE WAS ALSO ACTIVE IN
ADOPT A HIGHWAY. GAVYN ANGIE
DELAROSA WOULD ALSO GIVE OF
THEIR TIME AND THEIR MUSICAL
TALENTS TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
PERFORM AT DIFFERENT NONPROFIT
FUNDRAISERS THAT WERE GOING ON
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY. IN
NOTING HIS PASSING THROUGH THE
MENTONE CHAMBER. THE MENTAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WROTE GAVE
WAS A GREAT HOW FULL AND JOYFUL
PERSON. GAVE DELAROSA GAVE HIS
TIME BACK TO HIS COMMUNITY
STARTING OFF IN MOUNT VERNON THE
LATINO COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
THERE ULTIMATELY INTO THE
COMMUNITIES OF MENTAL. HE
CONTINUES TO BE A PILLAR HIS
FAMILY CONTINUES TO BE A PILLAR
IN OUR MEMORIES AND AS SOMEONE
THAT WE MIMIC AND MODEL TO
STRIVE TO BE FOR. I ASKED WE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF GAVE
DELAROSA. THANK YOU MISS ROSS
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. NUMBER
SEVEN INFORMED THAT TODAY
HAPPENS TO BE. THE FIFTIETH
BIRTHDAY OF KEVIN MCCARTY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO HAPPY
BIRTHDAY SIR. PLEASE WISH HIM A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY FROM SIX FEET
AWAY. MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY. JANUARY SEVENTH NO FOR
SESSION- CHECK IN SESSION MNDAY
JANUARY TENTH OUR FLOOR SESSION
IS AT ONE PM ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN.
ALL MOTIONS XABI CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING A FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MS BONTA
MOOSE. AND MR COOLEY SECONDS AT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY TENTH AT
ONE PM. WE ORDERED.